Insertions, deletions, and SNVs can really screw up
a coding region. But where do they come from?
>> Well, mutations can come from lots of different places.
But these types, in particular, predominantly come from replication errors.
>> So, do you mean, like, the DNA is actually replicated?
>> Exactly. Inside a cell, there's molecular machinery responsible. Doing all
the work for replicating the DNA. And sometimes it makes a mistake.
>> Does it fix its mistakes?
>> it does.
your body does a good job at fixing
mistakes. But even after fixing all those mistakes, it
still misses some and you have a mutation
rate of about one in every 300 million letters.
>> I like those odds, that doesn't sound that bad.
>> It's true, it doesn't sound too bad until you consider
that there are there three billion letters in the human genome. And
you've got six billion, counting both copies in every cell. So that
turns out at about 60 new mutations every time a cell divides.
>> Wow. That really does build up.
>> It does build up over time but, those
mutations are great new source of variation for new alleles.